it's me drew
ross and i at the commercial break he
keeps staring at me i go you do drag
race what yeah but this is like a drag
race level of transformation it's pretty
wild and you look so good thank you
rossie thank you all right what's next
all right well uh we talked about emily
in paris i'm obsessed anybody else
watched that show
i love it it's breaking records on
netflix and while filming it in paris on
location sounds like it would be so
glamorous insider reports that star lily
collins said it was a real pain in the
foot
because during filming she had to see a
podiatrist every single week because her
dogs were a barkin
apparently cobblestones and stilettos
don't mix
has anyone here had kids
like your feet are never the same
after the kids oh my god first of all my
foot grew three shoe sizes no
three i went from a six to a nine and i
went back down to like a seven seven and
a half my whole shoe collection's gone
really yeah i had to give it all away or
donated it well is it um do they hurt
heels i don't believe it or not don't
wear them but
i did a western movie did you say it
like that whenever you see a western i
did and i always will um
and um
they had to um i had to wear a real
corset
that was but i was uh like 17 so it was
totally different whereas now i would
rather eat glass than wear a corset yeah
another thing that happens after
children you're just like it's not worth
it
i'm looking at you right now you don't
need a corset okay look at look at her
hello
next this this we all turn to friends
for relationship advice but experts say
their advice is possibly bad
pop sugar reports that according to a
dating app survey 54
of gen z singles regret taking their
friend's advice
experts say your friend's advice is
questionable at best because number one
they can be projecting their own
relationship stuff onto you which may
not be for you and number two you might
have different wants needs and desires
for a relationship that maybe they can't
understand ross thought well that's a
really nice way to say maybe your friend
is a mess and you shouldn't listen to
them
i think right like it
it depends on the friends
we all have the friends who like you go
to for advice about relationships and
then we have the friends you go to for
advice about tequila you know there's
like different
areas of expertise
[Music]